yo welcome back to thug notes this week
we searching for answers at the bottom
of the bottom with the Sun Also Rises by
Ernest Hemingway after World War one
stunner Jake Barnes spending all his
time in Paris sipping juice and write
something I like to call the good life
one night while throwing back some drink
with the brother named Robert Cohn Jake
peeps some find Amy's the harlot named
Brett Ashley even though they still got
a thing for each other
Jake noted this girl too wild for him to
handle CJ got his junk straight stuff
during the war and ain't no little blue
pills gonna fix that to make things
worse
Jake ain't the only one macking on Brett
ever since she walked into that Club
Cole's eyes have been straight glued or
ass and he don't give a damn that she
bout to marry some thug named Mike
Campbell ain't no thing though cuz Brett
drops out of Jake's life like she always
do and hence the San Sebastian for a bit
couple weeks later Jake Brett and some
homies decide they're gonna hit up a
bullfighting festival up in Pamplona but
before they leave
Brett tells Jake on the down low that
she was holding it up with comb the
whole time she was in San Sebastian oh
wait
during the festival this whole gang of
white folk peeps some young Hood named
Romero who got the whole bull fighting
game so Brett got her eyes on this stunt
and it's not long before they started
doing the nasty next day cold start
flipping demanding to know where bread
is and straight [ __ ] slaps Mike in jail
when Jay comes to he wears that
coneflower Merrill hot in bed with Brett
and later whoop on his ass eventually
Brad and Romero peace out and hit the
road together but it ain't long before
Brett calls Jake de Madrid saying she
drop her marrow and be flying solo again
on their way out
Brett's say that her and Jake could have
had a ball and time together Jake just
responds
isn't it pretty to think so
if you want to go hard at this Fiesta
you best peep game at the two quotes
that stop this book the first is from
that gnarly beezy Gertrude Stein saying
you are all a lost generation Oh
Gertie giving a shout-out doggone peep
scarred by the deficit of World War one
for example Brett was a nurse during the
war and watched her man die only to
marry some weak-ass wife beater
so our girl ended up with some serious
emotional baggage that jacked up her
ability to connect with other players in
a meaningful way now Jake's cars ain't
no joke neither
cuz of the war Jake's sporting some
busted up family jewels which means that
he can't have no kids a generation is
literally lost son anyway taste that
theme it doesn't of all biblical like
with his second quote one generation
passeth away and another generation
coming but the earth abideth forever the
Sun also arises and the Sun goeth down
and haste it's to the place where he
arose all the rivers run into the sea
yet the sea is not fool and to the place
from whence the rivers come that they
return again we not only get in the
novel's title from Ecclesiastes easy but
it's also saying that ideas and values
don't go on forever like Jake say even a
fine for lots of the ain't in five years
dub dub one did more than just stacking
a lot of bodies it also killed homies
belief in the most sacred of things even
love playing that thug home and got
nothing but old-school romantic love for
bread but truth is chasing that love
only making them gets wasted and back to
all crank crank cuz in the shadow of
World War one romantic love and the real
deal no more partner cuz without the old
cold people gotta invent their own just
look at all them boys fighting for
Bret's fine self not only do they
compare her to the ancient temptress
Cersei from Greek myth but peep straight
up worship her even though this book be
filled with a bunch of white people
dancing and getting wasted on a rag they
ain't got no true happiness cuz I'm a
real the world is capable of such evil
that these players ain't never gonna
find a mean man looking for looks like
they just do them to keep sipping drink
and jacking around as they keep
searching I had the feeling as in a
nightmare that all being something
repeated something I have been through
and that now I must go through again you
know thanks for tuning in play us and
feel free to find meaning is some thug
notes way a fine philosophy indeed